rool est un monsieur georges fenech
monsieur asie dans mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse ce nouveau
secrétaire d'état au développement et la
francophonie monsieur jean marie le guen
monsieur le ministre ma question est
d'ordre personnel car il nous faut
aujourd'hui crever l'abcès
à l'occasion du changement de
gouvernement
vous avez quitté le portefeuille des
relations avec le parlement pour hériter
de celui de développement et de la
francophonie
certains d'ailleurs s'interroge sur les
raisons de ce qui s'apparente à une
rétrogradation ministériel mais de ce
fait vous allez donc devenir entre
autres je dis bien entre autres et au
long de la france l'interlocuteur
privilégié des pétromonarchies du golfe
or dans leur dernier livre intitulé nos
très chers et mir 2 journaliste bien
connu et digne de confiance je me cale
bruno et christian chesnot révèle que
vous auriez proposait alors que vous
étiez chargé des relations avec le
parlement en proposer à l'ambassadeur du
qatar en france de lutter contre le
qatar
ping pour ce faire à l'assemblée
nationale vous vous seriez fait fort
d'écarter les questions d'actualité et
gênantes pouvant provenir des dépôts
gauche mais à la condition qu'il fasse
appel aux services d'une société de
lobbying dirigé par l'un de vos proches
avec un coût mensuel de prestations fixé
à dix mille euros
si ces faits étaient avérés monsieur le
ministre il constituerait un très grave
système de corruption étatique attachée
à la présomption d'innocence monsieur le
secrétaire d'état ma question ne se veut
pas accusatrice cependant vous
comprendrez que l'opposition exige de
connaître et avec l j'imagine tous les
français votre réponse à cette mise en
cause de la pelure gravité et pouvez
vous nous préciser si à ce jour
vous avez déposé une plainte pour
défendre votre probité et notre honneur
la baronne est à monsieur jean marie le
guen secrétaire d'état chargée du
développement et de la francophonie
merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le député de me rassurer sur le
caractère polémique et diffamatoires de
votre question à un moment j'ai cru que
c'était là votre objectif et auquel cas
je me disais je me posais la question
mais où on est l'opposition pour en être
à ce point bien parce que s'agissant de
ce livre que vous avez l'air de prendre
évidemment je vous dis tout de suite que
bien évidemment je vais porter plainte
en diffamation
je vous le dis et je crois savoir
d'ailleurs que le statut de l'assemblée
nationale où la liberté de parole et au
talent est tel que je ne peux je n'ai
pas la possibilité de porter plainte à
votre égard je le regrette beaucoup mais
à d'autres moments si vous avez
l'occasion de vous exprimer je porterai
plainte également contre ceux qui
peuvent avoir ces paroles vous faites
référence à un livre monsieur le député
vous auriez pu citer la liste de tous
les responsables politiques et
singulièrement d'un certain nombre de
vos amis qui sont mis en cause
je sais qu'un certain nombre d'entre eux
ont également porté plainte que vous
aurez le souci par ces temps forcément
difficile pour la démocratie
je le crois de faire en sorte de
respecter d'une part l'honneur de ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont en responsabilité
d'autres pays et au delà de la
présomption d'innocence lutteront contre
un journaliste par ailleurs bien connu
mais c'est peut-être un lien avec votre
question comme étant un des porte
paroles de monsieur bachar el-assad dans
notre pays
[Applaudissements]